one week to e3 hi by this time next week
microsoft sony nintendo ubisoft EA who
else konami maybe if we're lucky but
i've had their press conferences so this
week on the show we're not going to play
any video games we're going to talk to
people about what we think might happen
this year at the Electronic triple I got
you three here to talk about as
Microsoft first of all last year's e3
for them was not right oh my god the
disaster heard round the world like set
the tone for the next like year of bad
news and backtracking for those guys
yeah when you're immediately
flip-flopping on your three press
conference two weeks later you did a bad
job yeah so let's talk about first of
all the latest flip flop with have which
is connect and Chris what do you think
they have to do with Kinect netted it's
like been taken a little but oh my god
so it's not in the box so what is that
that's set that sounds like a vote of no
confidence that's like sorry you guys
for the don't connect I'll cool you
don't have to have it but like Kinect is
a thing that's part of their system in a
rigid last year you know they do love to
show off how it's like voice commands
touch communal like all our gesture
commands they need to show the Kinect is
cool which I don't think they've even
done at all they've had a long time to
try and make the Kinect oh yeah really
have so than a long time to make that's
really trendy so skele me is that like
forever we've been waiting for that like
killer hid can that game or like you
know there's been some really good ones
like Don Central and stuff for really
great yeah it just never happened and I
don't think it's I don't think is gonna
happen on the scale that like wii motion
controls happen right there not it's not
a core it's not the integral like way
that you interact with the whole system
you know it's it's a peripheral it's off
to the side so i don't think we should
expect the big killer app for it i think
we need to they need to like lean into
this is a cool toy and like the tech in
this is actually pretty marvelous it has
demonstrated by all the non Microsoft
product uses the Machine of it for years
now so I mean like hacking them on their
pcs and stuff I made weird games at them
and I don't think we're going to get
like the single one killer app because
there's not quite the incentive that
there used to be because previously
developers who decided to make a Kinect
game knew that one hundred percent Xbox
one's had a kinect sold with them maybe
not
and in use but at least they're sitting
in a closet somewhere yeah now you can
buy an xbox one without a kinect and
that installed base isn't there anymore
so people have to get creative now okay
let's talk about games that first off
Microsoft ip's halo 5 Guardians was
shown off again last week or we've seen
more about that guys and what do you
think they going to do in relation to I
can ask you this looks on your big head
oh fun oh so they have it are these are
last year they've announced the official
title halo 5 guardian and that it's not
coming out till fall next year so it's
just gonna be some sexy trailer I think
a quick one it's gonna be more than the
teaser if we're lucky we'll get like 30
seconds of gameplay right but I'm not
expecting a full like 10 minute long
gameplay demo of a game that comes out
at the end of 2015 yeah Master Chief
wearing a poncho I don't know you tell
me who is that other character that it
looked like a girl but it's not
apparently it's not as another male
Spartan in the box art they reveal or I
don't know if it's just a toe injury
it's sort of the mirror of Master Chief
who knows if that has thematic relevance
or not but like you know they're gonna
have that but that's not the only halo
thing that we're gonna see you at the
presumably if they're getting that adds
stuff added away as well that I'm not
gonna focus on it too much during the
actual conference you would think which
a halo stuff the fact that they've
announced in a month before the show
halo stuff at the conference yeah like
absolutely and it's not what my I was
referred to is not just halo 5 but
there's also uh that the collection yeah
halo collection which is halos 1 through
4 that's coming out for the Xbox one so
they're definitely gonna show off some
like some of those glamour shots of like
oh you jump into the system and there's
the halo now it's in HD that's the first
time you ever saw it now in HD by the
guidewire don't you guys love halo
remember how it made us in the console
remember how this is the reason why
we're still here and it was so powerful
for them for them last time around and
this time it seems like Bob Jones Lana
dating that in the chacha SAS what are
Microsoft's exclusives now so let's go
through the ones they haven't they own
that they have internet so Gears of War
first of all are we going to see some
sort of gears stuff do you think I think
so yeah I mean they've got that
Vancouver studio working on it they
brought in rod fergusson who worked on
Gears of War back at epic yeah so I mean
they're definitely investing a lot into
the gears francese they bought that
franchise from epic so I feel like
they're at least going to tease it some
how whether or not it's a full gameplay
demo yeah idea and if you figure it's an
uphill battle for Microsoft this year
what's going to distinguish them what's
going to like gain them some ground
against Sony exclusives one of those big
things so we're so far these are like
remind people yeah why you bought that
xbox 360 why you bought that xbox halo
and gears are two huge factor yeah it's
a bit of a shame that they're leaning on
these old IPS they've had for a long
time as well yeah I mean this would be
the fifth game in the gears yagize
counting judgment so does it have a lot
of sparkle left in it is it gonna like I
think so generate headlines but go back
all the way back to the beginning and
like just reinvigorate everything that
we had when we first saw it you want it
Bruce yeah oh well not like I want that
back just a little light emergence day
gotta get legal excited I just saw with
with halo you get something like that
you'll get Marcus pics in her in a no
papa walking through the desert yeah
yeah he's just carrying a briefcase like
that'll be it guaranteed confirmed i'll
put money on it all right speaker what
do you think of quantum break uh I just
like to see it because you know they
they didn't do anything really last year
like he kind of came on stage and and
it's what they've been doing like what
every time they do a little tease they
do like a little video teaser going hey
we my name's Sam Lake it remedy and
idolized pretty good sound like it's
must not good that's a fine finish area
don't sell yourself short except for
Andy em and they come on and like just
go like oh we've been doing this and we
doing this and they show a little bit
more a little bit more but not much more
and last year's e3 they kind of didn't
really show anything at all they focus
on the TV stuff alaj yeah the kind of
the high concept so we got to be really
close to something pretty significant
right like the last video that they
released made it look great yeah and I
want to play it I really want to play it
mostly because the story's gonna be
incredible like the gameplay might be
crap but like the stories Damien have oh
it's the television stuff is a bit
strange because now it seems like it's
not coming out on xbox first they've
sold it to like ABC or something the
quantum break specific as a vision stuff
yeah apparently it's getting released
like similar cast or not just on Oh
regardless of where that ends up you
were definitely gonna see television as
a big part of Microsoft's Prescott yes a
because final one brick but yeah they've
announced their lineup for like you know
that Spielberg Halo series all these
like
they've contracted a original series
they've got pilots they've got shows in
production there's a list of them that
stuff that has nothing to do with video
games to yeah yeah there's like reality
shows there's a comedy show street
soccer documentary oh yes animated shows
and that was so that was part of it
that's so much part of their like
Microsoft and xbox one we are like your
whole entertain thing and so now I think
they have to folk they have to highlight
that in a big way because the way that
xbox one integrates with TV and brings
original content to the Xbox is going to
be another big differentiator but isn't
that like the problem is that they've
been buying this enter to this one box
thing and then what happened was Sony
came out and said screw all that we're
gonna talk about games and showed them
up like it's all those parts of the
conference's when they the Spielberg
Halen yeah so my nominally boring and
like the thing is like the two aren't
mutually exclusive video games and
entertainment stuff they don't do the
entertainment stuff they just have to
not forget about video games like
they've done for the past couple years
yes I think as long as like Phil Spencer
is saying a lot of the right things
right now like we have to focus on games
our e3 press conference is going to be
about video games we've gotten away from
that in the past and we're gonna try to
get back to it yeah so I I mean honestly
I'm fine with them working on the
original stuff there could be some neat
gems in there could be some turds in
there yeah probably yeah if we're
betting men and I think we are um like
the weird thing is at least Sony is an
entertainment company Microsoft have
like no business event are you saying
that goofy wasn't entertaining cliffy
Clippy had some gems what's Clippy
Clippy the little paper clip icon it oh
yeah come on you say this will be an
animated movie oh I see I think you are
you writing a letter it looks like your
writing it's going to be a gritty clip
eerie good games cause it's just weird
isn't it it's like Microsoft are making
all this television stuff like they have
no skin in that game ever I know like I
mean they you know the moment they
decided to make the xbox one a you must
have this your one stop shop for
entertainment they put themselves in
that game they've made that leap they're
saying you know with this whole
generation even more than with the xbox
360 well they're trending towards it
with the 360 and now they're obvious
last year we saw they're going whole-hog
base we're showing off all the sports
stuff all the you know TV integration
all you plug your cable box into your
xbox is literally an integral part of
your
system that that's their game now
whether they've got the pedigree or not
and I think they really have to emulate
it oh yeah and let's not forget
Microsoft is a different company now
than it was a year ago there's a new CEO
there's no president of xbox yeah
there's new leadership so I would
imagine they've got new ideas hopefully
they're going to steer the ship in the
right direction it started that program
that ID at xbox program but so far they
haven't released a lot of like super
exciting indie games at least happy is
probably because they'd super time force
yeah like super time force and they did
like a rerelease of strike suit zero
yeah but like this they certainly
haven't released like the breadth of
indie games that Sony has so they have a
lot of catching up to do I hope that
they're going to push indie games hard
at e3 cuz sony has shown that that
approach can work really well at least
for garnering like goodwill in the
community yeah sunset over dogs coming
out this year won a few games that's
coming out this year hey guys could you
trust people with orange soda you could
show that game in action but I think you
with a game like that that's a little
weird like you have to show you have to
show something that channels the player
experience so the others have something
to hook onto otherwise you there's a
reason we've been making the joke that
that game looks like a 90s go-gurt
commercial you know it just has that
over-the-top aesthetic and it's easy to
joke about but it could be really fun to
play so I think it has a great pedigree
yeah absolutely crackdown was fun so why
Kate what a big crowd what about
crackdown 3 yeah could we see a crack
den through it do you think uh crackdown
2 is kind of a wet fart of a game I know
it's kind of more this I mean I would
love to see a game on the caliber on the
level of crackdown wine is excellent
refreshing super fun 1086 TP agent agent
agent we need you to collect all these
even better looking orbits jump to the
top of a building agent yeah it is
cracked and a product of its time could
like a new because it was very much like
baby steps open world that era when
everyone was yeah where's yet does a new
crackdown bring anything to the table do
you think as long as it brings something
new to the table just something that
crack down to did not do yes it was just
a paint-by-numbers repeat of the
original game I mean with there's so
many games now that are that you've got
a prototype there's infamous there's
these great super-powered open-world
game
games yeah you really gotta gonna have
to carve out a significant niche if you
want to bring that crackling baggage
yeah the government's you got mad yeah
yeah then you're in you're sure a couple
more before we finish up rise to any
interest in a second Rise its if this is
risen wagons rumor come from rise to
it's not going to happen this soon
because they never would have because
all that technology it looks pretty
repeatable it looks like they can emit
oh yeah another one of those yeah where
anyone gets the end of the game ago I
need more I need quiet Crytek people do
when we'll look at them all up I'm
pretty sure Kevin play that game like
three times United yeah we didn't liked
it but he gave it like a four yeah I've
or something is why he just playing it
because it's a very little traffic so
rise to if it got the tech they've got
this you know they can render a
beautiful Roman world what should that
game be it shouldn't be the linear
beat-'em-up should it be should it be a
multiplayer melee game should it like
should it be you know troop Manimal like
back up back out to the Supreme
Commander of you and you're like said in
your phalanx is around yeah i don't i
don't know i got my dead wife III and
cover my what a rare that we can exports
rivals come out when i was talking to
them back a couple of months ago it
sounded very much like they were waiting
for microsoft to give them the
opportunity to go back to one of their
franchises yeah what do you think would
be a good play for them next well the
beginning of the 360 they came out with
perfect dark zero right so let's fix
that yeah you fix that you want a
perfect dark yeah I'd love that you
wanna yeah but a good one perfect yeah
not imperfect dark yeah not what I think
this is gonna sound weird but banjo
kazooie nuts and bolts that was great so
very it was a very open-ended game you
could like craft your own vehicle and it
had its own weird like behavioral
patterns depending on how you assembled
it and I think that taps into a lot of
what makes games like Minecraft
appealing these days yeah so I think
now's a good time for them to bring that
back and try to do it even better than
it did before do you want to see some
more viva pinata oh my god they made
that game for children there was a
cartoon with it it was a brilliant game
that then it's perfect but that game was
not for I feel like whoever was making
that that's Microsoft making the
television show and thing again it was
like the game with the TV show and they
were so like on compatible one was
for five-year-olds a moment's for like
25 year olds with loads of times get
these stupid chocolate hamsters to have
sex with you and those people loved it
yeah yeah and those 25 year olds are now
however old we are and so yes you should
bring back me up yeah I mean that has
super nostalgic value for a lot of
people and you know also that kind of
open creativity mode didn't I mean no I
reach out and I pick up my little what's
a dumpy viva pinata animal name I'd the
chocolate hamsters we have sex yeah yeah
yeah pick up to chocolate hamsters and
mash them together yeah right fable
legends ah that one looks kind of
interesting only because it's not a
fable game though like why I even call
it a fatal game because it's set in
Albion and looks like a fable game
because I my table here oh it's well
it's a dungeon crawler though it's not
like a story choice driven RPG it's like
a co-op dungeon crawler so but you can
play as the villain that's true you can
mess with do it's kind of got a little
bit of the evolved thing if you squint
hard enough and no lie to yourself will
evolve is again we're going to talk
about later but for now thank you all
for coming on and talking about
Microsoft rumors first party video games
and all that nonsense